today we're getting drunk and ranting
about celebs with Matt ballast I only
hear on the daily Denny hey what's up
you guys this is the daily Denny
happy Friday Tia forget everything you
know about the show because I'm throwing
the concept out the window
screw news I'm dedicating this episode
to my one of my favorite comedians ever
guys please welcome Matt Bell aside come
on in here Matt he's super tall so I'm
gonna do a little little step up here
there we go now we're perfect we're free
to look at us we belong on camera
together we do yeah I'm so happy you're
here
thank you mainly cuz I just like you or
someone I need a drink wine with I feel
like yeah you know this is like the
Internet's favorite drunk I think right
I guess so yeah that person I have to
own it now you do that's your thing yeah
before we get drunk since we're sober we
got to talk about your new book I know
everything is awful what a title
everything is awful yeah let me talk to
me about this because it's a filled with
some amazing amazing stories very honest
you keep it very real I know how brave
of you really thank you yeah I think
that's early reviews are in and
everybody is impressed that a I can
actually write and be it that I tell the
truth you do yeah you really do I mean
what inspired you to write this book I
basically I'm an awkward as hell person
and I wanted to write all of my really
awkward stories and explain how I became
the grumpy drunk that I am the amazing
grumpy drunk yeah this is my superhero
origins but what's your favorite
anecdote and story in here um my
favorite one we've just published the
first excerpt and it's about me I kind
of fell in love with my best friend in
college and then I I hid in his closet
as like a prank what you do as you do
right that's know and then there was
like a night where he brought a girl
over and I they spotted me right away
did this but it was still one of the
most awkward moments of my life and now
it's a story in a book and um I get paid
for it and we reap the benefits to I
mean these are lessons learned don't
hide in your roommates closet just don't
do it
yeah don't fall in love with your
roommate right her best friend I think
closeted things probably most people
know that already try it took me a
little while to find that out the hard
way reminder friendly reminder don't
hide in the closet a falling in love
thing you can't always help it that's
true yeah true
well it's me Z and now you're actually
gonna go on tour and support the book
right yeah kicks off in New York that's
where I live
but then my first show on the road is in
Chicago where I'm from I love it well in
case you guys don't know about Matt's to
be honest Facebook videos
he drinks wine and he rants so I feel
like we need to do that here on the
daily den Ian yeah are you down before
that we should probably get some wine
don't you think yeah hey thirsty yes
okay I know you're not used to sharing
your wine but that's fine it's better
for my liver if I share that's true I
mean I don't know how much to poi you
tell me when uh just keep you know I
like a heavy pour it is you know Friday
yeah that's good she goes first yeah
let's get a little sip in cheers to you
oh all right thank you huh sway
all right so oh is that good um sure I
don't know good one from a bad wine
that's true yeah it's six dollars no I'm
kidding
I got a list of entertainment celebrity
pop culture themed topics let's rant
away yeah okay number one the new
American Idol what are your thoughts on
that I just let it die give her back to
God uh it's Simon Cowell doing it no so
okay you have no saggy breasts to judge
no Sh
where do you go from there exactly you
need a saggy breasts Brit mm-hmm a drunk
dancer former dancer I volunteer as
tribute right I do that um and Randy
Jackson so I don't know unless you have
all three your hand to American Idol
again so now it's Katy Perry Lionel
Richie and Luke Bryan okay close close I
think it's too soon but more you know
good luck we'll see I know they do like
did it give it any time barely a year he
dad's
speaking of reboots there is a remake of
hocus-pocus coming to Disney Channel
without the original cast of Bette
Midler Sarah Jessica Parker and Kathy
Najimy no that doesn't even make sense
it's not who kiss wasn't computer no no
it's not also it's a Disney
channel original movie that's right addy
Cobb a rep for the network tells ET it's
a new iteration of the 1993 film and
deadline report it will be a new cast
reprising the rules but it's like what
no unless it's Hilary Duff Christy
Carlson Romano Raven LaBeouf Raven
different yeah her Shia should I could
play the virgin that's true great right
um I don't I feel like he's done enough
I don't know if yeah I don't know if
that candle is gonna respond to his
bland okay number three another headline
from this week blac Chyna sues the
Kardashians over Rob and Chyna
cancellation the reality series that is
my level of dramatics is it if someone
shuts down your [ __ ] you sue this you
take them to Kyle see you in court
higher like sebelum higher Lisa blue
I've showed you a good job she'll quit a
couple days later but she'll do a job at
first uh and then yeah take it to Judge
Judy I bet Christian raised like how do
you pick this into our lives there's
gonna be a law and order at the
Kardashians I need a drink after that
one okay last topic Beyonce's twins I
know you and I are both big Beyonce fans
yeah oh yeah I have no idea and it's
infuriating I'm pissed
where are they like stop hiding them I
forget what their name sorry I'm gonna
be honest uh Rumi and sir the girl is
Raveena the boy sir had to ask
Tina knows herself to clarify that for
me right wasn't sure no you have no idea
if any baby could be Beyonce's baby at
this point stru can pass a baby on the
street and you'd be that could be his
baby you're right I had to ask him to it
but I'm ready to see more of the twins
mom also she's been out a lot like who's
watching them she brings these twins out
though that is very true a lot she was
looking good at the title concert um
yeah where's that baby wait it's just
like went away no no way Beyonce's magic
she is Magic she's a unicorn she could
do whatever she wants you know and so
can you
thank you so much come here with us that
was fun cheers to you Matt you guys pick
up his book everything is awful and of
course he'll be hitting I'm drunk you're
going on tour nationwide city to city
yeah check about where can they find out
all the information are you can go to
everything
alfa book.com and that you can pre-order
the book there you can buy tickets guys
well be sure to like and share this
video
come on give Matt some love and we'll
see you guys on Monday I'm gonna finish
this and then I gotta go work out with
the trainer which is not good